president biden is traveling today to
highlight the benefits of his massive
covet economic relief plan which will
start putting money into people's
pockets very soon
luigi zhang is at the white house for
suija good morning to you where's the
president headed
good morning tony president biden is
going to pennsylvania today right
outside of philadelphia
as part of the administration's sixth
state swing this week to promote the
american rescue plan
and other key members like the first
lady and vice president kamala harris
already hit the road of course one of
the key measures
of the package is those stimulus checks
and the white house says that 85 percent
of american households will receive at
least 14 hundred dollars
we spoke with single mother renee
copeland who told us she is obsessively
checking her bank account
to see if the direct payment is there
copeland said she's barely making enough
as a waitress to pay the bill so she
isn't thinking about boosting the
economy but all of this money
will go toward bare necessities
it means i'm not in the firing anymore
i can step back from feeling like i'm
being engulfed in
financial flames it's it's a it's a cat
it's a time to catch my breath okay
you know just a little step ahead a
little something
um to get me to the next point
and despite polls that show the majority
of americans support this
plan cbs news has learned exclusively
that today
the republican national committee plans
to launch a counter-messaging campaign
to attack the plan on the airwaves on
the phone
on the ground to try to make the case
that
this money is not targeting the fight
against the pandemic
gail well try telling that to the
families because they certainly say it's
making a difference thank you very much
weeja